you're not really you you're just you
today and you're constantly you're
constantly changing and you're
constantly evolving
and uh being able to kind of look back
and and remember that retrospect how
back in those days you thought this and
today you you see things a little bit
differently and you understand that you
know
things are kind of not
the way you thought
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're going to be joined
by shelio moyal an international finance
and investment expert shelley leads i
angels with a compelling and hands-on
approach to the firm's investment due
diligence process investor relations and
portfolio management of the i angels
platform and institutional fund
ingenuity
shelley's experience as an investment
banker with goldman sachs and research
analyst at avenue capital equip her to
reality test the growth plans for early
stage innovative companies make
data-driven investment decisions and
architect deal terms to ensure equitable
profitability between investors and
entrepreneurs she is an active investor
who accelerates companies enterprise
growth with marketing finance recruiting
fundraising and business development
efforts
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you thank you for having
me
thank you for joining me today um you
know i angels is such a significant part
of the israeli ecosystem such an active
part of both on the investment side but
also you know i think you have more than
5 000 accredited investors on your
platform with over 250 million dollars
under management you're a board director
of some of the most interesting
companies in these real ecosystems so
it's a it's a real pleasure for me to
you know get to know you in these 20
minutes and sort of pick your brain on
on the founding of angels and you know
where you are today and how you got here
so shelley tell me a little bit about
yourself and then we'll dive into i
angels sure
so
um
i actually started uh
my career in investing
i started at ubs and then worked at
avenue capital as a trader and analyst
afterwards at goldman sachs investment
banking division
i always wanted to invest i always saw
myself as an investor today
as well
i angels i founded eight years ago with
morassia from my basement
um
i think really what's special about us
is the fact that we we built i angels as
a startup we weren't
looking to to build a vc in any way we
were we felt that there was a real need
on one hand for entrepreneurs to connect
with the world with investors from
different countries
and on the other hand for investors that
are serious investors looking for
relevant opportunities high caliber
entrepreneurs
uh serious uh serious people
uh and we saw an opportunity to to
connect between these two worlds
because we came from these two worlds we
both had an experience working with
investors working as part of corporates
we know what people are looking for but
we were also from
a burgeoning generation of entrepreneurs
people that went to the army with us
went to school with us
um really experienced the whole
proliferation of the israel tax
ecosystem
and and we felt that we can be a bridge
and so so we
moved to my basement and uh
you know started making phone calls and
traveling the world and speaking with
people and built a product and brought
on engineers and and product people and
basically uh
created a really easy way for people to
build their own vc in a way that's
professional and investment grade
so so walk me through really to though
those those early days you're sitting
with mo you know what what is sort of
the
you know what what is the vision what
what is sort of the intrinsic motivation
that is that is guiding you as you're
figuring out what type of investment arm
we're going to do and how do we want to
empower others to create their own
portfolios so what is sort of the the
mission that you're on
so at the time when we started the
mission uh
was mainly to
to provide uh
capital
and awareness and and access
uh to to the israel tech ecosystem by
the way the world is very different
today but when we were traveling the
world uh there were a lot of people
around that did deals in israel that
weren't successful not because the
startups weren't successful because the
the communication wasn't successful
um
and uh and we saw here here a real
opportunity to to make a difference we
also saw it through the eyes of our
chairman
david asia who he himself is a serial
entrepreneur
and um
and before we started i angels he had a
portfolio of many many startups and he
you know he kept chasing them for
updates the startups that were
successful he never heard from them and
he never really had the chance to follow
up and the only ones that he actually
did have the chance to follow up with
the ones that kept knocking on his door
for for more capital
and uh and it was very difficult to keep
track of no standardization of how kpis
are presented how information is
presented what is the deal structure
that makes sense for everyone and uh
and really the vision was to to change
all that and to really empower
uh
an ecosystem or a nation that's
partnership driven and and
win-win-driven and really if you look at
our platform this is what we're all
about we try to
bring uh on one hand to our
entrepreneurs
we we build uh strong relationships with
them that are based on
based on trust and communication
and um and responsiveness on one hand
and on the other hand from the investor
perspective also transparency and
fairness
and and ability really to to get all the
information and and make educated
decisions
right and so
you know you're you're starting this
often if we're looking i believe eight
years ago it was when that started right
it started
the ideation phase started eight years
ago but i can share with you that
seven years ago we
uh we started investing in that first
year we invested five hundred thousand
dollars
and in the second year we we invested a
million dollars and we would we would
call entrepreneurs and and uh convince
them to give us a hundred thousand
dollars and then
and then sell it to other people in ten
thousand dollar tickets so it was very
difficult and
then how it is today today we're
managing
we're we're actually managing uh
over 350 million dollars so it's not uh
250 anymore just this year we raised
over 70 million dollars since january uh
so
so the so the operation scaled quite a
bit
and uh
and yeah today we we've invested in 100
startups we've had 23 exits we've built
a vc fund a crypto hedge fund
now we're raising an opportunities fund
so incredible so and so we right now if
you're looking at i angels and you know
the role that it plays within the
israeli ecosystem what is that to you
sort of what what what role does i
angels play you know in in the if you
look you know from a bird's eye view at
the tech ecosystem
i think that uh the most significant
thing that i angels
provides
to
entrepreneurs
and i guess to the tech ecosystem in
general
is is a new approach and a new way of
doing things
a process that is uh that is structured
that is methodological that at any point
in time you
you know you know what you can expect uh
from the portfolio company's point of
view where we're incredibly flexible we
can answer
many of our entrepreneurs financial
needs whether it's uh funding for the
round whether it's secondaries whether
whether it's bonuses uh for for
employees whether it's a safe whether
it's uh
uh bringing in other investors under
under our uh structure and and spv
and uh
and really we you know we try to
we try to be the best investor that we
can for entrepreneurs
the type of investor that that we want
for ourselves
and
i love it and so
is the the female-led part the
female-owned and led vc how significant
was that already from the beginning was
that sort of you know he said you know
what we want this to be you know 10
years strong we still want this to be
the female at vc of the israel ecosystem
was that was that a a part of the
mission
no not at all first of all we encourage
as many
women to
to to join the ecosystem we see
ourselves as a as a springboard for
women many women that started in night
angels moved on to do uh great things
including entrepreneurship including dc
including uh corporates uh and and
actually part of our agendas not to be
the only women led uh no no of course
didn't mean only grab her but rather to
bring in uh bring in more women to the
ecosystem and empower more women to be
doing uh doing what we do
no no yeah of course and i didn't meet
only i mean a female at the vc and
obviously that's not that's not
something that you come by every day and
it is something very special and
something that i that i think is is you
know playing a pivotal role in the
ecosystem one thing i noticed by the way
is that we without even trying we end up
investing in a lot of women
we're we're actually why is that
i think that we're not gender blind
uh i think that we're very nice i think
that we're less biased
to be honest
because i was because we're working now
on our uh we're doing this video for for
i angels for the end of the year because
we had an incredible year we had 11
exits and many big rounds unicorns um
and so we decided to create this film
and then i noticed wow there are a lot
of women on this film a lot of women
founders and ceos and uh
and uh it's not just in your portfolio
it's it's of the successful part of the
portfolio yeah you're seeing a lot of
the women
even stronger yeah
incredible which part of this whole
process
you know does shelley really enjoy you
know if you're looking from the managing
the fund and and you know shaping in a
new type of investment arm all the way
to finding the right startups to working
with them as as a board director and i'm
sure that takes up a lot of your time as
well which part of this pipeline is
shelley really you know into
uh
i really love everything i really love
all the work
and just building eye angels and
just riding this uh
incredible wave
and uh and learning and and actually
being involved in all aspects of the
business and investing and business
development and working with investors
in marketing and building a product and
thinking about how
uh we provide better automation and
onboarding and and and i really enjoy uh
managing and working with my team
and recruiting and and building people
and and just uh
really uh everything from from a to z
obviously in the last eight years or so
you spent a significant amount of time
you know really understanding you know
the the vc and the tech ecosystem here
and sort of deciding how how what role
you want to play in it
if you look today
you know what's happening and where we
are are you satisfied is this sort of an
ideal situation either in your eyes or
generally in the vc's eyes or
you know as a as a thinker what what
where do you think we should be going
what do you mean by ideal situation
so you know eight years you know as a
pioneer and in what you do and as a
founder of a vc arm you're poised to
constantly think about okay am i doing
the right thing am i building the right
arm are we you know is the process
correct and sort of looking at a bird's
eye view and i'm wondering if we're
looking at this question today and not
just eight years ago when you founded
angels
you know what's happening in the
ecosystem perhaps that you think we need
to improve on or that you think that
angels needs to improve on or in general
i don't really look at the world that
way i you know i
i kind of uh i kind of accept what is
and try to make the most of it
i also see
in every situation i see benefits and i
see
disadvantages um
a lot of people for example ask me are
we are we in a bubble is this good the
valuations and and i mean look as an
investor it does make things more
challenging but on the other hand being
in an environment with where a lot of
people want to invest and there are a
lot of interest and entrepreneurs have
opportunities to raise significant
capital allows them to accelerate more
quickly and markets to develop more
quickly and products to be shipped more
quickly so there are different things
there are good things about it as well
because it also for example
um
you know where there's a lot of money
and there's a lot of interest also
brings a lot of talent and then that
trickles down also to students for
example who are deciding what their
career paths should be
so i mean this is just an example but
really
and and regarding what i angels if we
could or couldn't have do done
better or i mean i i don't i don't think
about these things because what whatever
we could or couldn't have done it's it's
not something that i have any control
over the only thing i actually can
control is what i'm doing today so
so
yeah of course and you know i'd love to
get to know you a little bit better and
you know if you look across your own
journey
you know you you came into angels
already having experience in the world
you've worked at some great
organizations very global organizations
so a lot of understanding there
where did you grow most
in the last seven or eight years is it
more on the you know the leadership side
is the more the business development
being able to to find
the right people to back and to and to
understand markets better where where do
you see the biggest growth on your on
your personal end
i think um
the the the experience of uh of building
a business
um it's very
first of all it's it's it's very broad
you're you're getting a lot it's very
multidisciplinary
um
and it's very humbling um i've i've come
from uh different organizations
uh but
but really
but really i i over the years
learned
how much how much i don't know
and uh really come to appreciate uh
appreciate that and uh and it's very
humbling and it's very helpful in
in kind of being uh thoughtful
and uh trying to learn quickly from
from uh
from mistakes or think that things that
didn't occur exactly the way you want
them to
um i think it
made me a better listener
um
was founding angels you know a similar
journey to what maybe some of your
founders are experiencing
that you're now that they're you know
starting to start you mentioned that
angels was you know a startup for uh
that morgan you co-founded are there
really similarities
i'm sure there are because when you
start when more and i started it was
just
the two of us and we wanted to yeah and
we wanted to build this and we wanted to
build that and we ended up being we're
the secretary where the sales person
where the yeah where the i remember two
years into i angels we finally brought a
legal like a
a person that's uh
you know a lawyer and and uh you know
you read every single contract you're on
every single call you're you're making
sales pitches for someone who for for my
whole life i was behind excel
spreadsheets that was uh you know that
was very enlightening all of a sudden to
really
be out there selling selling things
um so that's the first stage and then
there was a second stage where we raised
a little bit of capital we brought in
our first employees how do you adjust to
that how do you how do you become not
only uh an entrepreneur but how do you
become
a manager or someone uh that that people
want to follow
um right then you know and and today
we're experiencing other other issues
like scaling and you know how do you
make things better and more efficient
how do you build a culture
how do you create a dna where people
want to stay
uh so they're
there's never a dull moment i think many
of our founders go through
uh the things and the questions that
that we go through
i i love it take me back before
investing before the excel spreadsheets
everything
10 years old elementary school middle
school
you walk where did you grow up shelly
so i grew up in uh
for most of my childhood i grew up in
particular
what what sparked your curiosity you
know what fascinated you as a kid you
know roaming the world
so actually
there's something that that uh that i
was fascinated by i'm still very
fascinated by it um
when i was uh when i was in uh sixth
grade i had my first um
deep conversation
with that with a friend
fish
yeah and um and i remember that night
very well it was like into the night it
was still 3 a.m
and uh and i felt so
empowered i felt wow i was i'm analyzing
like real things here and like i'm
analyzing life and people and
relationships and i had all these kind
of aha moments
and uh and something that really
fascinated me was kind of the realistic
every few years i looked back at myself
then
and i said
wow i really i can't believe i thought
that way then like today i i you know i
think something totally different i'm
like i'm a totally new
enlightened person and it happened to me
literally every single year and it's
still i mean it still happens sometimes
and um
it it really made me realize
that
you're not really you you're just you
today and you're constantly you're
constantly changing and you're
constantly evolving
and uh
being able to kind of look back and and
remember that retrospect how back in
those days you thought this and today
you you see things a little bit
differently and you understand that you
know
things are kind of not
the way you thought uh so that's i love
it fascinated me and still and obviously
this goes back to this exact you know
same idea that you're saying before you
know we can look at the past and harper
on it and and think about it a lot but
but the life is moving forward and we
have opportunities every single minute
we get to reinvent ourselves and we make
it an intentional choice about who we
are and what we do and every minute that
we look back maybe we'll learn something
from it but it's also
not allowing us to propel forward
and and the same in the same rate and i
i think that it speaks very similarly to
what what you said before and actually i
really want to thank you for for coming
here i know how how incredibly busy you
are and and you know just looking at the
amount of companies that you're involved
in personally
through angels it's you know it's an
incredible incredible list and thank you
for all the amazing work that you're
doing for the israel ecosystem and for
your founders and for your investors
last question for you if there are a few
words that
mo
or any of your entrepreneurs or
investors would think of when they hear
the name shelley holmoyal what words
would come up
um
[Music]
i think they would say that i'm
relentless
yeah i can get that
um
[Music]
i'm a learner
like i love i love to learn i i love to
read i
i get through usually one book a week
still one today
um amazing
and uh
adventurous
yeah i love it first time i hear that
word i've been waiting for like 700
episodes to hear that word
adventure
thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy thank you for
i angels and thank you for these 20
minutes and
so thank you
[Music]